Speaker 1: Something I've been talking about
for certainly as long as Donald Trump has
been on the scene actively involved in politics,
is the rise of authoritarianism.
The the risk of tyranny that we're running
by allowing these people in power, along with
authoritarianism, is also white supremacy
and white nationalism and just outright racism.
And Chief, the chief purveyor in the United
States right now of this kind of rhetoric.
And what makes it most dangerous is because
he dresses up in a suit and goes on Fox News
every single night and has the most popular
cable news show in the history of cable news.
Tucker Carlson.
Well, this last week, Tucker Carlson has been
in Hungary giving Viktor Orban, who is a wild
authoritarian in the mold of Donald Trump,
Steve Bannon has called Viktor Orban Trump
before Trump was Trump, something like that.
And I want to play a little audio or video
and audio of a speech that Tucker Carlson
is giving in Hungary, knowing that this speech
is not for people in Budapest.
This this speech is for people back home.
This speech is for Americans to hear.
And he is signaling something.
Let's take a look
Speaker 4: looking at these buildings, which
movement, not simply because they're old and
some have bullet holes, which in my view are
a very useful reminder.
I wish I lived in a city full of bullet holes
in the building.
Speaker 1: We're going to stop it right there.
And the reason we're going to stop right there,
because this is laughable.
This is the same man who whined and complained
about having to cower in his house while protesters
protested outside.
And he is in fear, whining, yet I wish I lived
in a town where there were bullet holes in
buildings as he romanticizes this disgusting
Speaker 4: because every morning you look
at them and you think to yourself, it could
be really bad because it's been really bad.
There's a lot at stake make wise, sober, long
term decisions or else you could wind up with
more holes.
It's true.
Speaker 1: It's true.
Tough guy.
Strong man.
Tucker Carlson never served one single minute
in the military in uniform, has never put
his life in harm's way, has never put his
life in danger for any cause.
And he stands there hugging himself.
Talking about how he wishes he lived in the
city with bullet holes in the buildings.
Speaker 4: I would love you and I could spend
all day leveling very accurate accusations
against the American foreign policy establishment,
but the main one would be that they have no
sense of how bad things can get.
It's this is the bad side of the upside of
America.
America is an optimistic country, always has
been came from all around the world, showed
up in this mostly untouched continent with
the most fertile farmland in the world and
an ocean to separate us from the lunatics.
And it gave us the feeling that anything is
possible and everything has been possible.
And I'll never stop being grateful for that.
We're proud of it.
But the downside to the flip side, the obverse,
the other side of the coin, as you say, in
Hungary, is that Americans have no sense of
how bad things can get.
Mm hmm.
That actually could be a lot worse.
Our physical isolation cuts us off from the
history of the rest of the world.
There's not a passion to study what happened
before in a place that you're building a new.
Right, right.
Yeah.
We don't have a sense of that.
So I love your bullet holes.
Let me just say, I'm probably the only visitor.
Our nation is complimented your small arms
and artillery.
But here's what I like more about the landscape
of Hungary.
A few Soviet remnants notwithstanding.
It's pretty.
It is pretty.
The buildings are pretty.
The architecture of Lintz
Speaker 1: architectural critic Tucker Carlson.
So, listen, what Tucker Carlson, I believe,
is doing here is romanticizing the bullets
in the building in the wake in the direct
aftermath of an attempted overthrow of the
United States government, a violent insurrection
that took the lives of Americans and attempted
overturning of a free and fair election.
Tucker Carlson sits here on foreign soil under
the protection of an authoritarian goon named
Viktor Orban and says these things criticizes
the United States foreign policy.
It has been practice for presidents.
To to to tread lightly, even even foreign
dignitaries, you don't criticize your country
while away.
Even when Obama made what conservatives call
the apology tour, he did not do that.
They criticized any thing that they could
perceive as a criticism of the United States,
even when there wasn't one.
And the script has flipped, now we have Tucker
Carlson doing that very thing and being roundly
applauded by it, by conservatives.
And doing this, romanticizing signaling to
the insurrectionists while denying that an
insurrection took place.
We all witnessed with our eyes what took place,
what happened with horror.
If you are a reasonable person, you witnessed
it and now we're being told the sky is green,
not blue.
That's not what happened.
This
is calculated.
Uh.